[Music]
you know Americans have a lot of great
qualities and one of the is is a general
work ethic I think you know we're a
nation of hard workers and that being
said I think sometimes we reach down too
far into our youth and expect them to
produce sooner than there then they
should be able to I think people gain a
tremendous amount of wisdom when they
travel when they wander when they allow
themselves as I did to get lost and
maybe you'll find yourself somewhere or
at least traveling forces you to be
social it you have to get directions you
have to learn where things are you're
attuned to your environment you have to
be more careful about the weather and
where you're lodging is going to be
where you're going to eat how you're
going to get from one place to another
when you're there what is it you want to
see how can you find a place for you to
actually just rest it's it's it's an
experience like no other I love to
travel
and I enjoy not knowing where I am
it's an unusual thing I'd sell it and I
purposefully teach that to my daughter
who's now 24 years old to not be afraid
I'm not knowing where you are so I'll go
for a drive or go for a walk in a
different city and my wife will sit do
you know where you going oh not really
just kind of exploring different places
and as long as you have a sense of the
direction you'll find your way you'll
figure it out and I do that in foreign
countries as well just kind of wander
and meander and trust that you know
you've paid attention to at least the
basic requirement of where where you
have to get back to in order to find
find your way home but I think it is I
think I think we we look down now to 16
year-olds and say where you gonna go to
college what are you going to do for the
rest of your life and it's like they're
sick they're not fully baked yet how do
they know give them a break just say
look I think after high school take a
year off take two years off join the
Peace Corps
travel go figure things out or just
enjoy yourself for the first time in
their lives they're adults and they
don't have to be somewhere they're not
told to be somewhere get used to that
freedom get used to having the the need
to self-govern yourself you know to be
able to employ self-discipline or not or
you realize oh my god I I'm really
slovenly if I'm not told I need to go to
class I don't go I need you might
discover something about yourself
I need order I need that I like that
some people love to be said this is
where you have to be and this is what
you need to do are you that type of
person or a you type of person that that
wants more freedom in your life and I
think exploration traveling it provides
that in 1976 I had just finished my
second year of college and realized that
after an experience in an elective
acting class that I wasn't going to be
the policeman I thought I was going to
be that it was it was better if I didn't
continue on with two more years of an
administration of justice major because
I knew I wasn't going to become a
policeman so I thought I better just go
figure out what it is I want to do and
so I hopped on back of a motorcycle my
brother was in the same position really
two young guys who were not quite sure
what was in store for them and where
what Avenue they should go down so we
both hopped on our motorcycles and we
took off we left California I had about
a hundred and fifty bucks in my pocket
or something and and soon ran low of
funds and we had to get jobs along the
way what was great about it is that we
had total freedom we didn't know exactly
where we were going we didn't know how
long we were going to stay in any given
town if it appealed to us we would stay
and and explore different places and
historical sites if it didn't appeal to
us we took off again we slept on golf
courses on cemeteries back of mortuaries
schools anywhere we can throw a sleeping
bag a little patch of grass and that was
our home for the night and you know I
was I was 19 20 years old it was it was
fun and you could do that then and
that's that that's the time you want to
do it that's the age you want to do it
and in retrospect I realized that I took
off on this trip which lasted two full
years in an effort to allow myself to
get lost to be lost and to figure out
while I'm gone
what it is I I really should be doing
with my life so I finally determined it
was something right I wanted to allow
myself to get lost so that I could be
found
basically as what it was and after two
years it was during that trip that I I
had an epiphany that I really wanted to
become an actor and do everything I
could to put myself in a position to
make a living and be a professional
actor for the rest of my life
[Music]